[Musique]
cuincy mise à mal un diplôme n'est par
le dr cette semaine j'imagine que vous
nous avez pas exemptés du sujet que j'ai
choisie pour clore l'année de 21 juste
avant de débuter les fêtes avec toutes
les annonces qui se fait autour de la
montée de la cave il le choix la presse
canadienne cette semaine n'a pas été
de parler de la commune comme
personnalité de l'année où les effets de
la colle vu comme personnalité de
l'année mais vraiment la première place
a été dédiée aux enfants autochtones qui
sont jamais revenus des pensionnats
suite à la découverte justement des
tombes des fois un anonyme des fois des
tombes de masse pour ne pas dire
autrement des camps d'enfants qui ne
sont jamais revenus des personnes qui
sont allées de façon forcée vers les
pensionnats autochtones pour ne jamais
revenir parce qu'on ne parle et quand
même beaucoup dans les dernières années
des 159 enfants qui ont été ou pas
seulement des effets des pensionnats de
tout ce qui a amené après ce système là
c'est à dire l'art hors des années 60 on
parle aussi tous les effets justement à
long terme début des violences et
tortures psychologiques ou physiques qui
ont souvent été
le quotidien de beaucoup de ces enfants
là mais l'on parle de ceux qui ne sont
jamais revenus
une réalité qui a frappé les canadiens
de plein fouet parce que ça a été un peu
compris avec la commission vérité
réconciliation
qui est même des pensionnats qui avait
eu des abus qui ont été faites et un
réveil collectif aussi par rapport au
fait que c'était des systèmes qui était
dirigée par l'état mais aussi par des
églises dont l'implication de tout ça et
le fait que beaucoup beaucoup de
canadiens ignorait même que les
pensionnaires existe et que c'était un
système qui avait été mis de l'avant et
je veux juste vous dire non quand même
après loin pour moi je me rappelle les
années 20 10 quand les survivants des
pensionnats essayer de se faire entendre
par rapport aux atouts qu'ils avaient
vécu dans les pensionnats et des fois
des atrocités des meurtres qui ont été
témoins dans les eaux des témoins à
cette époque là et le monde mais non
c'est pas vrai c'est quoi cette
invention et a fallu attendre jusqu'à la
commission vérité réconciliation
les 94 de recommandations qui en sont
des coulées touche tous les effets ça
soit les femmes assassinées disparu que
ce soit la période tous les effets qu'on
veut dépenser mais l'on parle des corps
d'enfants qui ont été laissés sur les
terrains qui ont été trouvés grâce à des
détecteurs
et qui ont amené une réalité
enchères est malheureusement en hausse
excusez moi l'expression
de ce que c'était les pensionnats de cet
été l'effet à long terme des fois du
manque de soins du manque de
d'humanité qui existait dans ces
pensionnats là donc ça lui a amené un
moment de recueillement énorme ça leur
ramener beaucoup d anciens pensionnaires
un endroit qui était très difficile
c'était aussi difficile pour les enfants
des survivants de voir d'entendre les
réalités de leur part encore une fois
mais deux se rencontrent parfois il ya
des temps des angles des grands parents
qui sont jamais revenus
et je parle des grands parents parce que
non mais des grands-parents les grands
noms de la grande tente qui sont jamais
revenus des pensionnats et toute cette
paire tchèque a découlé chemin des
disparitions des
jeunes autochtones dans les pensionnats
et la réalité que beaucoup de gens
pensent moment et inventer pour beaucoup
de personnes même il ya un désir de ne
pas reconnaître ce pan de l'histoire
cependant avec cette reconnaissance tout
c'est avec l'arrivée qu'est l'éthique et
les canadiens ont eu pour tout décor de
mon échauffement au canada
d'agir pour pouvoir trouver les
coordonnées un moment de deuil et de
recueillement ça l'a amené quand même
des choses mais ça n'a pas été fait par
le gouvernement quand même deux rangs
par la population qui ont amené une
pression qui ont amené une demande
encore quelqu'un et enfin citoyens de ne
pas laisser le canada comme ça avec des
cadors ventes ou des tapis donc il y
avait quand même beaucoup d'appels sur
les réseaux sociaux pour dire et mettez
les drapeaux en berne d'autres appels
qui peuvent être ramenés une journée de
recueillement et la journée la
réconciliation a été officialisée ce
temps n'annonce pas encore contre les
états dans les cours que soient les
courses près en cour supérieure pour
faire reconnaître les droits des enfants
autochtones et tranquillement avec la
pression de la communauté de la
population canadien ça fait avancer les
actions du gouvernement beaucoup plus
rapidement que par le passé mais vous
comprendrez qu'on vit encore des fois
des confrontations idéologiques je pense
jeux sont faits que l'ajout de la
réconciliation n'est pas férié au québec
par exemple et les
beaucoup troublé parce que on pas
d'efficacité pour ne pas donner une
journée fériée dans le coeur des
personnes notamment les codes agents de
la réconciliation et moi de faire
marquer on a une journée au canada pour
les canadiens pour les québécois une
journée pour célébrer d'entités et une
journée pour se recueillir autour des
personnes qui ont trouvé important
au niveau des communautés autochtones on
vient d'avoir ses impressions du 21 juin
dire comme une célébration pour célébrer
l'identité autochtone bien sûr ben là
aujourd'hui la réponse est à son elle
n'est pas reconnue la même manière dont
va même pas encore d'avoir cette
reconnaissance d'une journée de
recueillement de deuil national et on
parle pas de deuil des 200 ans on papote
juste l'importance à ce qu'on parle des
patriotes souvent comme une journée de
recueillement mais de vous j'en ai deux
souvenez lampard des enfants qui ont
touché nos parrains qui ont touché nos
grands parents sont connectés à notre
vécu et on ne donne pas encore
la dignité de foi nous recueillir et de
pouvoir donner aussi du temps aux
canadiens et aux québécois de venir se
recueillir avec nos autos de cette
réalité donc c'est seulement si vous y
pensez on ne prend une journée où ce mot
dire qu' on s'arrête un moment qui on
sait maintenant pourquoi on l'est on est
arrêté aujourd'hui c'est ça
donc ça c'est des enjeux qui ont été
touchés par la disparition
mais d'autres choses sont arrivées là je
pense beaucoup aux 40 milliards
justement qui ont été alloués pour les
enfants qui ont été enlevés à leurs
familles dont on parle de l'art hors des
années 60 et toute la discussion qui
vient au taux 2 ans lors d'un encan
d'argent on avait pu lui c'est une
saignée à blanc envers les autochtones
chat mais il faut rappeler au public
indien celui qui seront justement au
dédommagement des victimes de ce système
là que peu importe ce qu'on fait dans la
vie on leur doit des fois redonnez qu'on
a mené des conséquences si je ris ton
change je te dois quelque chose si j'ai
un effet sur ta vie si j'ai commis un
crime je dois pays en allant en prison
eh bien le gouvernement canadien
présentement est en train de devoir
compenser pour son manque de regard
envers les droits se trouvent les droits
daptone envers les droits humains et
doit compenser les familles les victimes
donc si je suis nommé fait c'est pas de
l'argent gratuit qui est devenue une
compensation financière envers les
victimes du système canadien du système
québécois
contexte que je viens en ville et les
décisions qui ont été prises donc si un
impact il faut qu'il y ait une
compensation et on sent pas qu'il était
majeur dans le cas des communautés
autochtones et continuellement il faut
plaider pour pouvoir dégager le ballon
on a parlé des phillies enfants dépend
seulement on a parlé des survivants des
pensionnats parler des femmes
autochtones l'on va parler de la rof des
années 60 quand les enfants ont décrit
leurs familles et mis dans un système
qui est peut-être d'adoption forcé aux
dégâts puissent d'adoption de secret et
même une fois de surreprésentation
dans les services à l'enfance et qui
encore aujourd'hui des conséquences donc
ré paris pour pouvoir se réconcilier
pour aller de l'avant sans qu'on ait
apporté ce bagage continue elle est une
des choses qui est important de se
rappeler c'est quand on encore
l'histoire des survivants l'histoire des
pensionnats et qu'on pense au corps des
enfants qui sont encore sous terre de
chaque communauté va gérer la soie de
rapatrier les corps soient d'avoir des
enquêtes soient d'avoir même juste le
moment de se recueillir de retrouver les
personnes qui leur étaient chers qui
sont jamais rentrés chez eux
il ya toute notre génération et nous
quittons ce haut fait que nos enfants
ont l'âge
aujourd'hui d'aller dans les pensionnats
il ya une politique existait et qui
aurait pu continuer d'exister
aujourd'hui
nous ont dit qu'on aurait pu rentrer par
la porte et venir chercher mes enfants
donc vous comprendrez que c'est quelque
chose qui est encore intensément vécue
parce que c'est encore vrai c'est encore
vivant et les personnes sont encore
ancré gérer tous les impacts de ces
systèmes alors c'était une longue
chronique mais c'était pour honorer
quand même la pensée envers les jeunes
n'a pas envers les survivants les
familles même avec un 2 qui doit faire
d'eux des images qu'elle avait
d'elle-même pour faire avancer la
pression qu'on peut mettre aussi sur les
gouvernements pour faciliter justement
la réconciliation et pour la faire durer
n'auront pas
faut comprendre que toutes les époques
ça mais aussi des effets sur la
structure donc il ya encore des
problématiques les langues autochtones
ne sont pas encore reconnus comme des
langues officielles et sosa vient de
toute la divination vers la culture des
programmations ça vient encore de la
surreprésentation des enfants dans les
services sociaux sur la représentation
des représentations dans les milieux
carcéraux est tranquillement en
approchant en guérissant en transformant
la relation et bien on va amener une
véritable réconciliation
alors je vous remercie beaucoup pour
votre écoute je vous remercie
infiniment de partager les chroniques de
les écouter dans les milieux
universitaires que je cégep secondaire
ils servent parce que c'est une parole
qui veulent partager je pas la seule
parole mais justement ces paroles qui
est pas encore nécessairement partout
dans les médias on essaye à l'instance
autochtone de pouvoir faire entendre ces
voix là on essaie aussi à travers toutes
les sortes de médiateurs travaillent
toutes les formes de militance de faire
entendre nos voix et je pense que si
c'est une chose qui est très symbolique
est très représentative de la militante
et la prise de parole les communautés
autochtones c'est qu'elle est toujours
été fait avec une main tendue dans un
esprit de réconciliation mais aussi dans
un esprit de vérité et donc je pense
qu'on on peut dire que les effets sont
justes bénéfique pour le canada qui va
guérir elle même les problématiques de
la colonisation alors suite de l'année
lb en fin d'année et on va se retrouver
en 2002